[Music]
this is a family business
daddy's faculties are
waning the next logical leaders would be
amber and myself you're not the only
married people in this family me and bj
are also strongly betrothed not a real
family no kids slam i like that one i
don't got time for kids cause i'm trying
to keep this fresh physique fine i'm not
trying to be all loose and stretched out
like amber's played out pastrami
remember this house
jesse and i are blessed to be teaming up
with lyle and lindy listens on a new
business venture
zion's landings christian timeshare
resort on the sunny beaches of florida
we got to align ourselves with the best
i mean only pure thoroughbreds that's
exactly how we see you all too we do
powerful christian horses type folks
[Music]
this is junior friend of mine from
memphis who's this hot piece of tail
that's my daughter judy oh excuse me
and uh this one of her girlfriends well
i'm not a lesbian partner i'm her
husband b.j no dj he's big dick in you
there's something else y'all should be
aware of a reporter is in our backyard
i'm doing a piece on your family you
think i haven't tussled with the press
before well a story i got isn't on you
don't dance around which one of my
family are you after who are you trying
to smear
[Music]
we are in this reporter's crosshairs
let's go save our family
i'm gonna try to blackmail me tell the
story
let's not waste time
you don't know who you're messing with
now i'm on the way up and you on the way
down
gunmen just tried to assassinate your
father
all we have to do is just think for a
second no we don't have to think we have
to drive my door's opening back
up now
god dammit
[Music]
you